Dr. Peterson,
I have an interview for medicine coming up very soon.
It's structured in the MMI format and it's intensely competitive.
Any tips on how to stand out from the rest?
Okay,
well the only thing I could say is that
two things.
One is really pay attention to the interviewers,
right?
Super attention.
Like don't glare at them.
Like you're aggressively paranoid,
but like make sure you're focused on them.
And then the other thing I would say is say what you really think,
like tell the truth.
It'll make you,
first of all,
if you tell the truth and it doesn't work,
then you know,
maybe that's not the school for you.
That's something to really think about.
Um,
and if it doesn't work anywhere and you tell the truth,
maybe medicine isn't for you.
And I know that might be a terrible shock,
but let's assume that you are genuinely properly motivated to study medicine.
Then tell them what you think.
You know so many people when they go into an interview try and they do this when
they write essays too is try to tell the interviewers what you think they want
to hear it,
but you can bloody well be sure that virtually everybody who's being interviewed
is going to do that and I don't think that's very advisable because if you don't
manifest yourself the way you are,
then there's no way that the path that's proper for you can reveal itself.
I know that sounds sort of mystical,
but I don't know how to put it any better.
The best way to stand out in an interview always assuming you're competent and
that you've done the preparation,
you know and that you're not living a lie is to actually say what you think and
hopefully what will happen is that there'll be other people on the panel that's,
that's,
that are looking at you who are of the same type and that would characterize a
good position for you.
A good place to be.
If there are people like that and they'll know what you're doing and that will
that,
then they'll think you know that person,
you know they're there,
they'd be good.
They're straightforward,
they're honest,
they're,
they're tough.
They're,
they can say what they think.
And if there aren't people like that on the panel,
then I would say,
you probably don't want to go there anyways.
So that's what I would,
that's what I would do.
Be True to yourself,
you know?
But that also assumes that you've done your homework and that you're prepared
and all of that because if you're a useless jackass and you're yourself,
while obviously that is going to work.
So good luck.
Good luck with your interview.
But I always think that like you,
the other thing too is don't treat the interviewers as enemies.
You know,
if that's hard,
because if you're kind of petrified about the potential outcome and you feel
intense judgment,
then you're likely to go in.
They're kind of afraid and nervous and,
and,
and maybe even resentful.
It's like
you've already done enough so that you're going to get interviewed.
So in some sense the interviewers are hoping that you'll be great already.
You know,
there might be the odd cynic in there who's trying to figure out a reason to
give you an x and check you off the list.
But most of the people sitting there,
if they have a clue,
are going to be looking for good candidates and they're going to assume that
you're,
you've hit threshold.
And so it's not like they're not on your side.
And so that's a good thing to keep in mind too.
You're not going in there to,
to face a panel of enemies,
you're going in there to face a panel of the sort of people that you're likely
to be in 10 years.
So that's another thing that's really useful to keep in mind with interviews in
general.
I would say.